public sénat en partenariat avec l' afp
les échos radio classique présente
[Musique]
jean louis bourlanges député modem des
hauts-de-seine est le premier invité de
l'épreuve de vérité en cette année 2010
8 désormais diffusée le lundi jean-louis
bourlanges bonsoir bonsoir et merci
d'être avec nous d'avoir accepté donc
notre invitation de public sénat la
vérité n'est pas une épreuve affecté
n'est pas une épreuve nous le verrons
cours de cette émission en tous les cas
réaliser toujours bien sûr comme ces
dernières années ce sera encore le cas
en 2018 avec la sp avec radio classique
et avec les échos trois grandes
questions vous seront posées jean louis
bourlanges un la transformation est elle
en marche 1 vous répondrez à jean
francis pécresse alors j'ai vu que vous
avez regretté récemment un début sitif
d'emmanuel macron par rapport à valéry
giscard d'estaing vous vous expliquerez
là dessus se piquerait deuxième question
à quoi sert donc le modem dans cette
majorité présidentielle paul briat vous
le demandera enfin troisième question
emmanuel macron est il une chance pour
l'europe mickaël szames s vous
interrogera sur le déploiement du
président français hors des frontières
est aujourd'hui jusqu'en chine mais
d'abord une toute première question
d'actualité
[Musique]
un record de demandes d'asile en france
plus de 100000 l'année dernière sur dix
ans on le voit la courbe monte en flèche
dans le même temps on apprend et c'est
le ministre de l'intérieur d'ailleurs
qui le dit ce matin dans une interview
au progrès que le nombre d'étrangers non
éligibles à l'asile mais reconduit à la
frontière en fait est en recul depuis
quelques mois depuis quelques semaines
est ce que tout cela vous inquiète
écoutez je ne vois rien de très
surprenant dans cette montée des
chiffres hélas ils reflètent de façon
tragique la tragédie moyen-orient
personne ne peut c'est pas du tout
'l'indice d'une dérive d'un manque de
contrôle c'est simplement le fait que
nous avons des quantités de plus en plus
impressionnante de personnes à
l'ascension oblige et d'albanais et
bruits valeur & carry un bien sûr
toujours évoqué les problèmes mais y
aller il ya le moyen-orient mais la la
la la la région sahélienne n'est pas non
plus de tout repos on a des problèmes
les albanais c'est un problème très
particulier et là il faut être sans
doute est particulièrement attentif à
ses causes et et et au traitement de
cette affaire donc je crois que c'était
le vrai problème c'est que nous avons à
la fois des demandeurs d'asile en termes
politiques cela nous sommes équipés
juridiquement sinon administrativement
pour les accueillir mais nous avons des
demandeurs économique que nous refoulons
quand ils ne sont pas quand ils ne
correspondent pas à des décisions qui
ont été prises par nous et ce qui est
inquiétant c'est pas exactement de
questions mais comme dirait georges
marchais c'est ma réponse c'est nous
avons toute une zone grise qui se
développe par exemple les émigrés
climatique c'est à dire des gens qui ne
peuvent plus vivre dans l'endroit où ils
sont hélas nous sommes très des armées
est en tout cas tant qu'on n'a pas
effectivement définit une doctrine poser
des principes ils n'ont pas à être admis
accueillis au titre vous avez là la
turquie est adoptée semble-t-il pour un
président de la république quand il
s'exprime sur le sujet on l'a bien vu
ces dernières semaines je n'aime pas le
je n'aime pas l'expression de l'île et
winum et je crois que si vous voulez moi
je préférais jeu les mots fermeté donne
l'impression qu'on a un choix entre
appliquée
exagérément la loi ou l'appli caire
insuffisamment moi je crois qu'on doit
appliquer la loi ce qui fait problème
c'est le manque de rigueur
administrative c'est le manque de
capacité à traiter les demandeurs
d'asile ce sont les délais et c'est à ça
d'ailleurs que le gouvernement entend
entend faire échec c'est les délais tout
à fait excessif avec lesquels on demande
aux magazines sont administrateurs
preuve de rigueur administrative
d'efficacité administrative et non pas
dire que on va resserrer les boulons ça
ça plaît beaucoup à ça c'est des légumes
au risque que les faits c'est sacré je
vois les choses aller avec l'humanité
certainement enfin c'est cela dit nous
ne nous payons pas de mot non plus la
situation de la plupart de ces personnes
est absolument tragique pour voir ce
qu'ils ont fait pour arriver là où ils
en sont pourquoi ils sont partis les les
atrocités qu'ils ont subies en cours de
voyage c'est une affaire qu'on ne peut
pas aborder sans un minimum d'humanité
je m'étonne que certains partis
politiques puissent aborder tout ça avec
dada coeur léger en dix ans on a rien à
faire de ces gens là ce sont des
personnes humaines mais c'est ce qu'on
peut par exemple recensé les sans
papiers dans les centres d'hébergement
d'urgence il ya une polémique de ce
sujet et là-dessus gérard collomb tient
bon écoutez moi je vais je crois de
l'humanité je l'écouté je ne me sens pas
je ne me sens pas compétent pour définir
exactement sur le plan administratif la
meilleure technique faut être dans
l'administration pour le faire je crois
que la la l'identification de ces
personnes doit être fait le plus tôt
possible
donc ensuite tout est affaire de moyens
tout est affaire de conditions tout est
affaire de dignité de l'accueil et
dignité du traitement c'est vraiment une
question de travaux pratiques alors on
en saura plus bientôt puisque le
ministre de l'intérieur prépare donc une
loi elle sera dévoilée au mois février
mais déjà j'ai vu que les tensions sont
apparues au sein même de la république
en marché ce que c'est au sujet des
migrants selon vous que via
effectivement peut-être que des
frondeurs vohémar rim émerger dans la
majorité présidentielle
moi je ne crois pas à la notion de
fraude parce que pour ferrer veut
frapper aux frondeurs de l'ancienne
majorité les fondeurs de l'ancienne
majorité était des gens qui étaient en
opposition frontale avec la ligne
économique et politique du gouvernement
donc ça ne pouvait pas coller est là
tandis que là c'est simplement une
question
d'appréciation de l'humanité par rapport
à la rigueur administrative c'est
beaucoup plus une question de dosage le
souci de gérard collomb me paraît très
très très légitime c'est de dire on ne
peut pas se s'accommoder d'un système
qui ne nous qui nous conduit à ne pas
dégoûter un demandeur d'asile dans un
délai inférieur à 2 ans au bout de deux
ans on le dit ah bah
il dit 6 mois mais ça ne suffira pas
parce qu'au bout de six mois vous pouvez
aussi vous avez adoré mais ce serait
quand même un immense progrès et salwa
attentes essentiellement à tendre vers
c'est simon vainqueur à atteindre ces
six mois par la suite de l'épreuve de
vérité avec jean francis pécresse le
directeur de la rédaction de radio
classique
[Musique]
bonsoir francis
bonsoir monsieur pécresse
est ce qu'elle va à ce point
assez vite et assez loin
je crois qu'elle va certainement assez
vite car je crois vraiment que dans ce
domaine dans le domaine des non pas des
réformes mais des changements il ne faut
pas confondre vitesse et précipitation
moi je pense que un délai le problème
c'est de ratisser de labour est profond
c'est ça la question des réformes il
faut aller au fond des choses et je
crois que ça n'implique pas
nécessairement
qu'on aille à toute vitesse je prendrai
un exemple je vois que le ministre dont
je me sens le plus proche dans son
action c'est le ministre de l'éducation
nationale monsieur bill halter monsieur
blanquet abba voyez vous il ne propose
pas une réforme d'ensemble clés en main
que les parlementaires seraient amenés à
voter en quelques semaines il propose un
certain nombre de mesures concrètes
précises allant dans deux directions qui
sont absolument
stratégique centrale
d'abord la lutte contre les inégalités
des l'enseignement primaire et
maternelle donc d'une part d'aider des
opérations précise dans ce sens et
d'autre part le rétablissement d'un
rapport beaucoup plus exigeants au
savoir et aux disciplines fondamentales
ça ce sont deux éléments centraux mais
vous ne le ferez pas par une réforme en
dix ans en faisant un texte de loi ou
entendez décret donc je trouve qu'il
faudrait peut-être plus de pragmatisme
et plus d'attention aux affaires
administratives prenons l'exemple de
l'asile que nous venons d'évoquer je
crois très bien que monsieur que
monsieur collomb s'oriente dans cette
direction mais je crois que le
rapprochement la limitation des délais
ce qu'on veut obtenir c'est d'abord des
opérations des réformes des changements
administratifs aujourd'hui alors vous
attendez quand même beaucoup sur les
questions économiques la transformation
trouver rappelle alors de michel
grossiord mais exactement on tourne
très critique sur notamment sur le
budget 2010 8 sur l'insuffisance des
réductions d'effectifs de fonctionner
sur l'insuffisante réduction du déficit
et de la dette publique est ce que là
dessus ça va assez loin je n'ai pas posé
le problème en termes de réduction du
nombre de fonctionnaires je crois
qu'effectivement il ya certainement trop
de fonctionnaires notamment dans l'est
dans les collectivités territoriales et
aussi sans doute dans une partie de
l'appareil d'état mais je pense que le
nombre de fonctionnaires c'est quelque
chose qui se définit à posteriori qui se
définit quand on a fait les réformes
quand on a évalué les besoins quand on a
compris en quoi les fonctionnaires
faisait double emploi ou pas c'est pas
quelque chose pendant que j'étais quand
même je comprends la démarche de nicolas
sarkozy qui disait on ne remplace pas un
fonctionnaire sur deux c'est peut-être
bête et méchant mais c'est assez
efficace mais je crois que là il faut
aller très au delà et effectivement ma
mon inquiétude tout au long de la
période budgétaire de lacaune nous
sommes sortis il ya quelques semaines a
été que l'objectif de réduction des
dépenses publiques n'a pas été
clairement affichée en termes
suffisamment ambitieux on a dit et je
comprends très bien et c'était
nécessaire qu'il fallait absolument
tenir les 3% de déficit
du pib qui était un engagement que nous
avons pris que nous avions pris
notamment vis-à-vis de l'europe
vis-à-vis de nos partenaires allemands
mais il fallait aller bien au delà
comment va-t-on faire comment sur la
longue durée va-t-on opéré une réduction
des dépenses publiques est ce que ce
sera sur l'état est ce que ce sera sur
les systèmes d'intervention et là je
trouve que la réflexion n'a pas été
véritablement même engagé publiquement
de façon précise c'est ce que là dessus
vous n'avez pas le sentiment qu'au fond
on est en train de rater une occasion
une nouvelle fois jean claude juncker le
président de la commission européenne à
une bonne expression est dit c'est quand
il fait beau qu'il faut réparer le toit
de la maison pour dire il faut que les
réformes en france soit faite maintenant
parce que la conjoncture est bonne oui
j'ai appelé en écoutant jean marc daniel
que c'était une phrase de kennedy
une des nombreuses phases de john
kennedy le président de la république
dans la cité u l'autre jour mais devrait
s'inspirer de celle ci pourrait
s'inspirer de celle ci je crois alors
effectivement les réformes c'est très
simple quand on en a besoin on les fait
pas parce que quand il fait beau on les
fait pas parce qu'on dit tout va bien
l'argent rentre à flot donc les déficits
vont se résoudre de même et quand on
encore quand la conjoncture tourner on
n'a plus d'argent mais on dit alors on
peut pas on peut pas imposer aux pays
qui est déjà traumatisée par des
réformes un effort qui sera
effectivement sont une source d'une date
asseman de la croissance est jugée hier
le premier ministre dans le journal du
dimanche je rappeler l'impératif de
réduction du déficit public donc jeune
homme et je crois que l'autre assuré je
suis rassuré non non je serai rassurée
quand je verrai les chantiers semaine à
seulement des actes je verrai d'abord un
diagnostic parce que vous savez je ne
suis pas de ceux qui disent que on peut
réduire les dépenses publiques comme ça
quand vous regardez les dépenses de
l'état par exemple où lé voulait réduire
pas dans la justice
chacun sait qu'il n'ya pas assez de
greffier le juge était pas dans la
police on est que sarkozy s'y est essayé
ça n'a pas marché dont les hôpitaux vous
voyez très bien que bon ça c'est pas
l'état mais c'est le système de santé
papa chez les professeurs vous voyez
bien que les professeurs sont à la fois
pas très très nombreux en france je
parle et et si messi donné que les
comités le plus est-ce qu'on peut
certainement il faut réfléchir
et pas dans l'armée enfin donc ça prend
beaucoup de choix la ferme des portes
l'état je ne crois pas mes errances les
collectivités le reste et collectivités
je pense qu'on a cédé devant les
collectivités viables je pense que le
mot ça s est une confrontation très dur
en plus politique parce que les
collectivités territoriales sont tenus
par des élus de grande qualité savoir ce
qu'elle parvienne à ce que les gens leur
marche ce n'est pas la façon dont je
parle mais appelle l'ancien monde c'est
à dire des gens qui sont globalement
proches de l air ou proche des
socialistes et donc il ya il ya une
espèce de tensions politiques je pense
qu'on ne doit pas abordé fronton devoir
aborder les problèmes de réduction des
dépenses de façon intelligente parce que
si on demande simplement aux gens de
baie c'est leurs dépenses ils vont
frapper l'investissement et pas frappé
le fonctionnement or on a besoin
d'accompagner les collectivités dans la
diminution des dépenses de
fonctionnement mais les grands domaines
ce sont les domaines d'intervention
sociale c'est à dire qu est ce qui coûte
au terme masse très chiant c'est la
retraite et les retraites c'est le
logement
cc le lui l'unedic c'est
le système de sécurité sociale et là on
a vraiment on est homo béaba d'une
réflexion stratégique
j'ai écouté ce qu'a dit la ministre de
la santé mal à buzeins qui dit est que
ce soit dans des des soins inutiles qui
sont prodigués par contre dès que
l'horizon mais là aussi comment
passe-t-on aux travaux de ce centre
pertinents alors donc l'accident le
chantier celle à qui on peut faire une
purge en maître
je ne crois pas à la commission de la h
au pub c'est ce sont des ce sont des
mesures instantanées alors que nous
avons besoin d'une thérapie de pluri
annuel mais une thérapie pluriannuel
quand vous annoncez ça c'est toujours
que vous voulez rien faire donc il faut
à la fois à préparer de façon
extrêmement rigoureux heures ce que vous
faites sur plusieurs années et commencer
par quelque chose les uns après les
autres donc mercredi s'ouvre la
concertation la discussion là je sais
pas négociations sur la réforme de
l'assurance chômage est ce que c'est là
qu'il faut faire des économies massives
et notamment grâce à un meilleur
contrôle de la demande d'emploi pain de
la recherche d'emploi par les chômeurs
est ce que c'est une source d'économies
parce que c'est très contesté d'abord je
pense que là il ya une certaine
contradiction une injonction paradoxale
comme on dit quand on veut faire savant
du côté du gouvernement puisque d'un
côté on nous dit qu'il faut
effectivement gagner de l'argent là
dessus ou du moins en dépenser moins et
d'autre part on essaie de monter des
systèmes de l'assurance-chômage une
innovation un chômage volontaire si je
peux lui dire qu'ils sont quand même
assez contestable personnellement cédant
programme présidentiel donc j'ai été élu
dans le cas du programme présidentiel
donc je m'incline respectueusement
mais je crois que c'est pas l'idée du
siècle un de commencer à dire qu'on
accepte volontairement
à l'assurance chômage alors qu'on a déjà
beaucoup de difficultés à financer ceux
qui sont pas ce qu'ils perdent leur
emploi mais enfin donc je crois dire que
le gouvernement est en train d'évoluer
de restreindre de restreindre ses
ambitions dans ce domaine
c'est à dire vous avez déjà fort mais ça
nous on ne mangeait pas là je jouais on
voit bien que on sent une une timidité
devant l'ampleur du coût que
représenterait cette affaire on verra ce
qu'il en sait on verra ce qui en
résultera mais je n'ai pas
d'informations pratiques alors sur le
sur le plan du jeu deuxièmement nous et
le contrôle je ne crois pas du tout que
la la sévérisation du contrôle sur les
chômeurs soit une source importante de
revenus je crois qu'elle est nécessaire
elle est nécessaire parce que vous ne
pouvez pas laisser des populations au
chômage en déshérence sans vous occupez
200 vous occuper d'elle sans sang le
sang les accompagner sans exiger ce
qu'il faut exiger d'elles des efforts
précis de longue haleine répéter pour
accéder à l'emploi vous avez un devoir
d'accompagnement à devoir de
responsabilisation permettant là la
mobilisation est là
le retour à une volonté d'employabilité
de la part d'eads et des gens au chômage
ont bien il ya vraiment une nécessité là
mais c'est ça l'objectif parce que c'est
pas là dessus qu'on va gagner ce genre
existent aujourd'hui il ya il ya une
convention d'assurance chômage de 2008
je crois qui permet de le faire est-ce
qu'il faut véritablement faire une faire
une nouvelle alors la nouvelle sur les
réserves et raison je pense que les
outils les outils existent depuis la
réforme introduite par nicolas sarkozy
il ya certaines choses qui sont
j'écoutais l'autre jour dans je ne sais
plus quelle radio ce que je me savais
pas et elle n'était pas apparue jusqu'à
présent quelque chose de très
significatif le vous avez pôle emploi
peut prendre quelques sanctions dans un
certain nombre de cas quand le le
chômeur ne se présente pas un rendez
vous etc mais les vrais interruption
d'indemnités ça dépend du préfet et bien
c'est donc un pouvoir qui appartient au
préfet est bien dans la plupart des
préfectures il n'a pas été prévu de
service de fonctionnaires
gère cette affaire là donc c'est
simplement par défaillance
administrative si je puis dire c'est
simplement une loi qui qu'est lettre
morte mais ça c'est la vérité en france
en france on y perd profite beaucoup
trop le rôle des lois on attend beaucoup
trop de la loi et pas assez d
aménagement concret négocier et de ce
point de vue là ce qu'a fait madame
pénicaud et je crois exemplaires
merci merci c'est un francis on a
compris qu elles sont non pas vous
réservez vos impatiences à leur assure
la transformation économique et social
attentes vos attentes voilà sur la
transformation du pays la suite de
l'épreuve de vérité maintenant avec
paulo brille à notre confrère de l'
agence france-presse
l'épreuve d'immunité
bonsoir paul soir votre question au
député modem jean louis borloo à quoi ça
sert de modems drainage au rite et
présidentielle aujourd'hui et pour
l'instant ça je vous parlerai
franchement moi j'ai dit que j'avais été
interrogés à la fin de l'année sur le
sentiment que j'avais j'ai dit en tant
que citoyen je suis comblé par les six
premiers mois des manuels macron en tant
que parlementaire je suis frustré parce
qu'effectivement je trouve que la
majorité d'une façon générale n'a pas
vraiment trouvé sa place dans le
dialogue avec le gouvernement nous avons
un gouvernement qui prend ses
responsabilités qui est composé de
personnalités extrêmement brillante
conscience d'un certain nombre
consciente de ce qu'elle doit faire mais
vraiment tous m'ont ne s'intéressent pas
beaucoup à ce que pense si tenté qu'il
pense à ce que pense le parlement donc
j'ai voyez j'ai été longtemps député
européen je peux vous dire que quoi
qu'on dise du parlement européen c'était
autre chose parce que le parlement
européen c'est un système dans lequel
vous êtes à égalité avec à l'oeil la
connaissance impressionnable c'est moins
bien à vous êtes un as beau et c'est pas
moins bien je veux dire c'est moins
libre - on n'est pas prise en compte en
tant que tel le 2 avril est nature des
moniales à votre dessin de
fonctionnement c'est le coeur de la vème
république c'est le coeur de la vème
république et c'est à quelque chose à
laquelle que la vème république
c'est un défaut la vème république de
beaucoup de gens l'ont dire dévié depuis
50 ans jacques chaban delmas avait
essayé de lutter contre sa valeur chaque
fois le président arrive alors on avait
dit la gauche par les voeux mitterrand
et parler du coup d'état permanent il
est arrivé vous avez raison le coup
d'état permanent est devenu vraiment
permanent donc c'était mitterrand qui
décident est tout et c'est ensuite on a
toujours eu des choses comme ça avec ma
chirac sarkozy 21 alors ma cour je ne
dirais pas que c'est pire mais c'est en
tout cas moi je n'étais pas
parlementaire avant donc j'ai du mal à
faire des éléments de comparaison mais
en tout cas pour un don moi qui ai
beaucoup vécu dans d'autres milieux
politiques européens je ressens cela
comme une anomalie un peu frustrante je
sais bien que même en angleterre il faut
obéir mais faut dire que tous les grands
sujets que j'avais à coeur par exemple
j'étais contre
l'institution de lier fille j'étais
réserve est plus que réservé sur cette
réforme du gouvernement précédent mais
qui a été acceptée par celui là qui
était le prélèvement à la source
j'attendais comme je les dis des choses
en matière de en matière de réduction
des dépenses et j'ai eu l'impression
d'avoir eu un excellent accueil sur le
plan personnel de la part des ministres
même normal hein mais oui cause toujours
on t'aime bien on invitera toujours à
dîner on discutera avec toi mais
franchement c'est ailleurs comprendre
aux instructions c'est à dire comprendre
aux instructions mais alors aux drm du
parlement est ce que la vie des partis
et la décomposition politique est
dangereuse finalement ce que ces douars
les 10 - phoebe quasiment inaudible je
n'ai pas répondu avec à votre question
sur les partis politiques je veux le
fait je suis rôle du modèle jeu si je
suis au modem c'est parce que je ne suis
pas en marche gt gt newman est mis en
marche avant et je ne suis pas dans ma
phase que je n'ai pas aimé la façon et
ne gêne pas la façon dont leur marché
constitué les parlementaires sont de
grande qualité à on a on à gauche on
s'est un peu gausser de tels ou tels
qu'ils étaient maladroits moi même j'ai
eu un tel incident avec talent
parlementaire déjà très sympathique par
ailleurs peu importe nous avons quand
même des gens qui sont de qualité qui
ont des des compétences en pl la wii
pour matière la commission des finances
de l'assemblée nationale madame de
montchanin et très remarquée mais sur le
modem est brutale une forte majorité on
vous entend pas non mais alors là oui
alors là c'est là où ça ne va pas parce
que d'une part en marché complètement
prise en main c'est vraiment une
courroie de transmission
alors que je le rappelle macron a été
élu sur une demande de démocratie
participative c'est difficile la
démocratie participative mais au moins
qu'on respecte la démocratie
représentative est donc alors nous est
donc le d'une part en marche les plus
écoutés et nous nous sommes dans une
situation très très intermédiaire très
insuffisante mes amis ont tendance sont
optimistes les démocrates-chrétiens sont
toujours confiant dans l'avenir heureux
de ce qu'ils font et c'est sympathique
bienveillant c'est formidable d'être
modem à je dois dire que je suis comme
je suis dans une situation de très très
grand confort personnel intellectuelle
et morale c'est la faute mais revendique
et non pas du tout mais c'est mais il
faut il faut peser il faut avoir le
courage de 2,2 de gueuler de dire non de
d'affirmer ça et là on sent que sans
aller à une culture de l'insoumission
que nous réservons que nous abandonnons
monsieur mélenchon une culture delà de
l'exigence mais pas les on ne veut pas
non mais vous pourriez pas vu durant
n'ont pas non non nommé de metz je crois
pas que ce soit comme ça je vais dire
qu'on peut on peut aborder les questions
à fond en ce sens en rapport de force
ans et essayant de voir qui a raison qui
a tort quand les parlementaires émettre
des observations ce ne sont pas
forcément toujours des observations
idiote quelquefois mais pas toujours et
donc ça mérite d'être discutée et quand
on a raison ça mérite d'être prise en
compte c'est une question de culture et
pourtant le président et le premier
ministre sont toujours très très
populaire mais leur cote de popularité
n'arrête pas de grimper
qu'est ce que vous en bourse est
mortifiée ça justifie ça va s'arrêter on
a beau aimer parce que ce raciste les
français sont ils aiment le chef c'est
le roi d'accros c'est très simple les
français pour cela il sort de 6ème
république
on veut faire on veut escamoter le
président ça marchera jamais les
français élisent le chef de l'état a eu
même c'est le rhum il est à l'elysée
c'est le rhode mais qu'est ce qu'ils
veulent c'est que ce soit l'europe qui
gouverne et alors les parlementaires il
dit ils disent des choses idiotes les
français sur les parlementaires ils
gagnent de l'argent etc c'est fou mais
la sévérité il ya d'une seule chose
c'est que les français se demandent à
quoi servent les parlementaires alors
c'est tout c'est une vision vous suis là
votre démonstration on peut se poser la
question oui mais on peut se poser la
question et moi je crois que l'une des
solutions ce sera oui il faut y être
mais là il faut mener ce combat mais ça
n'intéresse plus personne parce que la
démocratie représentative n'intéresse
plus le monde vous avez des gens qui
sont pour le pouvoir du président
pouvoir
mentalité un peu consulaires je dirais à
la napoléon et puis vous avez des gens
qui sont pour la démocratie
participative les réseaux et puis les
pauvres gars comme moi qui sont attachés
à la démocratie représentative à tout le
monde s'en moque un peu c'est dommage à
quoi servait parlementaires ils peuvent
bloquer une réforme constitutionnelle si
ils ne sont pas trois cinquièmes à la
halle à voter massivement est ce que ce
sera le talon d'achille des manuels
macron ce cette absence de 300 kg m à
seulement trois cinquièmes il faut
d'abord que la réforme soit voté en
termes identiques dans les deux chambres
il faut avoir une majorité au sénat une
majorité à l'assemblée nationale et
talon d'achille alors je ne me couche
pas ça dépend ce que ça dépend comment à
chivas conduire parce que tout tout et
tout là car ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire que vous n'aurez pas une réforme
constitutionnelle si on négocie pas avec
qui doit-on négocier notamment avec
gérard là on va l'écouter justement
parce que lille négocié et il l'a
rappelé encore hier il a ses lignes
rouges sur la réforme du parlement
notamment bien sûr j'ai plusieurs lignes
rouges ou très fortement clignotantes ça
c'est ma première ligne rouge c'est que
le département où la collectivité unique
et le lieu de référence de l'élection le
second des sujets c'est que je suis très
attentif parce que je n'oublie pas le
premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle à une france fracturé en
cat et puis sur le cumul dans le temps
oui on savait que ça concerne 12
sénateurs sur 348 aujourd'hui ça vous
concerne pas d'ailleurs même si vous
êtes
exactement vous voyez que si on veut
faire gadget on se précipite là dessus
et si on pense que c'est pour nourrir
les populistes alors ça ne suffira
jamais qu alors c'est un gadget et à
l'interdiction du cumul des mandats dans
le temps moi j'ai toujours été hostile
ça je les fais du sport dics son
interdiction j'ai toujours été favorable
à l'interdiction du cumul de plusieurs
mandats simultanément parce que je crois
qu'on ne peut pas être sérieusement
maire d'une commune importante ou
président d'un conseil général ou
président d'un conseil régional et en
même temps faire vraiment son travail de
législateur et le contrôleur du
gouvernement à un mot pas lieu à
l'assemblée nationale au parlement ça
oui mais le cumul dans le temps j'ai
toujours trouvé que c'était une très
mauvaise idée et qu'à la limite année
est inconstitutionnelle en car au nom de
quoi pourrait-on interdit aux et les
concitoyens et aux électeurs de voter
pour quelqu'un qui n'a en rien démérité
et qu'ils auraient le souhait de voir
élu dans un point pour gérard larcher
c'est lui qui va remporter le match mais
au final je ne sais pas mais je ne sais
pas si il faut pas que ce soit un match
michel vasseur il faut que ce soit une
heure de là c'est un élément je crois
effectivement que ça ne passera pas si
ça dépend ce qu'on veut faire de tout ça
dépend qu'est ce que veut qu est ce que
voudra quesque de quoi sera faite la
réforme est ce qu'on voudra diminué de
combien voudra-t-on diminuer le nombre
des parlementaires moi je suis favorable
à une diminution du nombre de
parlementaires mais ce que je n'ai pas
ce que je n'ai pas dit qui est aussi une
réponse à la question qui est posée
préalablement c'est qu'à mon avis la
grande question c'est celle du mode de
scrutin et je j'ai des idées en matière
de mode de scrutin je ne suis pas sûr
hélas qu'elle soit là encore vraiment
prise en compte par le gouvernement je
crois qu'il faut un mode de scrutin qui
restent à l'assemblée nationale
majoritaire ma non troppo et surtout
qu'il maintienne et c'est une loi c'est
facile à faire techniquement qui
maintiennent l'équilibré à l'intérieur
de la majorité je ne veux pas je trouve
que ce qui ce qui nous perd c'est un
système dans lequel un président qui a
25 % des voix par le jeu de tous les
mécanismes de scrutin majoritaire
présidentielle puis
législatif et cetera arrive à avoir une
majorité absolue ce qui veut dire que
75% des gens se retrouvent en dehors de
la majorité parlementaire je crois que
là il faut changer ce système autre
question pour revenir au modem il ya
jacqueline gourault qui aujourd'hui est
en charge la corse au gouvernement
est-ce que alors elle doit négocier m
naturellement avec nationaliste est-ce
que vous est ce que vous pensez qu'elle
va céder à des revendications
nationalistes est ce qu'il faut le
souhaiter on va d'abord c'est un
excellent interlocuteur ou un une
excellente interlocutrice qu'a choisi le
gouvernement pour négocier avec les
corps je connais bien la corse ma femme
et décoche il fait des périodes
administrative en corse j'aime beaucoup
les corses et c'est pas des clients
faciles on peut discuter on verra on
verra ça je crois qu'il ya tout un
ensemble de choses qui me paraissent
extrêmement difficile on ne peut pas
remettre en cause on ne peut pas par
exemple avoir des décrets
qui serait écrit en langue corse et en
français parce que ça ce serait une
source de confusion générale revanche il
peut y avoir effectivement des
traductions des choses il peut y avoir
un développement la langue corse et tout
un ensemble de choses qui sont qui sont
possibles sur la propriété les la
propriété immobilière je crois considère
comme totalement absurde l'idée qu'on
réserve à des indigènes en quelque sorte
alors qu'est ce que c'est qu'un
indigènes ce qu'il faut être corse est
ce que quand vous avez un encore ce que
vous vivez comme monsieur achille
peretti qui était maire de neuilly
pendant des années et ce qui la régate
conserver son droit à être considéré
comme corse ou pas bon ça n'a aucun sens
mais malone il n'est pas né encore
comment oui mais on va pas commencer à
ben oui mais a demandé aux joueurs alors
il doit alors oui mais là la citoyenneté
française elle sur d'autres bases et ça
ça n'est pas négociable maintenant il ya
certainement beaucoup de choses qui sont
négociables avec beaucoup de pouvoir et
lyon on a déjà commencé parce que la
collectivité corse c'est quand même un
sacré poids qu'il aurait reconnu une
autre question mais la dernière david
une actualité du jour c'est le nouveau
vers des porte parole dans marche
monsieur nezzar où on a découvert qu'il
ya quelques années il avait twitté dans
des termes en des termes injurieux ou
insultant
est-ce qu'il a encore sa place on ne
porte parolat dans marche après les
tweets qu'il a pu écrire il ya quelques
années on parle de monsieur ryan nezzar
donc oui
il a écouté moi je suis tir je ne suis
pas démocrate chrétien mais je suis
démocrate et chrétien et je suis donc
pour le pardon des offenses à même je
trouve que je j'en ai un peu assez je ne
connais pas cette affaire a donc que ne
pas juger du cas d'espèce du tout du
tout vous avez vu ces tweets qu'il a
effacé insultant pour des personnalités
politiques avec des termes vraiment un
jury était là les français les français
ont dit ça pendant très longtemps ce
qu'il faut c'est qu'ils expriment il l'a
fait
je pense qu'on ne peut pas on ne peut
pas que ce climat de suspicion générale
alors maintenant c'est extraordinaire
parce que on accuse on accuse les hommes
politiques de tous et là on accuse les
hommes politiques d'avoir été hostile
aux hommes politiques ça devient quand
même un procès assez compliqué non
l'adoption thompson hézard rédemption
non je ne dirais pas je connais pas j'ai
pas bien d'étudier cette question je ne
sais pas exactement ce qu'il a dit mais
je crois que il faut cesser de chercher
des choses comme ça partout les hommes
et les hommes et les femmes politiques
ont des responsabilités très lourdes il
faut qu'elle les assume bien s'il fait
des erreurs aujourd'hui il faut qu'il
soit sanctionné
maintenant ce qui s'est passé il ya une
vingtaine d'années se passe si vieux on
va pas faire tout ce qu'ils font là
dessus je me sens bien incompétent
pourra évidemment on t'a reconnu en tous
les cas entendue en tout cas votre
mansuétude com merci beaucoup
kolo boya dernière partie de l'épreuve
de vérité on va parler de l'europe est
maintenant sous toutes ses formes avec
michaël szames est public sénat
[Musique]
enfin michael st michel ibos ambitieux
bourlanges alors c'est un peu question
emmanuel macron est il une chance pour
l'europe oui je crois que c'est
indiscutablement une chance pour
l'europe je crois qu'il a fait le bon
choix
qui est de dire que sur l'europe il ne
fallait pas aller à reculons il ne
fallait pas biaisé il fallait bien poser
le problème bien poser la perspective et
dire que de toute manière quelles que
soient les formes que prendrait
l'engagement européen de la france c'est
en la construction d'une europe unie que
ce jour à notre avenir à part allons
plus loin est-ce qu emmanuel macron est
devenu le nouveau leader de l'europe non
je peux vous savez ces notions de leader
vous savez même le général de gaulle
n'était pas le leader de l'europe quand
les allemands n'ont pas voulu non pas
voulu le suivre sur un certain nombre de
choses ils lui ont dit on s'est arrêté
là avant le robert schuman a lancé
l'idée européenne en 1950 il était temps
en condominiums permanent si je puis
dire avec conrad adenauer quand giscard
a fait avancer l'europe considérablement
il a été en étroite symbiose avec helmut
schmidt quand mitterrand
toujours des moteurs c'est ce que vous
devez descendre ce sont les matériaux et
encore quand emmanuel macron lors de ses
voeux dit aux européens j'aurai besoin
de vous parce que c'est pas un peu
présomptueuse que c'est pas un petit peu
à être trop lourd
écoutez c'est un sénoufo je ne sais pas
si quelqu'un d'autre je ne sais pas si
j'aurai j'aurai besoin de vous ça peut
s'interpréter de deux manières soit
effectivement de façon un petit peu
critique que vous étiez là voté de dire
je suis déjà votre chef et caetera et
donc vous devez me suivre soit aussi de
dire que la france ne fera pas les
choses tout seul ça peut s'interpréter
des deux manières dans tous les cas il
s'engage au nom de l'europe dans ses
dernières prises de position va parler
de la turquie dans un instant et
aujourd'hui même de la chine puisqu'il
est en déplacement d'ailleurs il a
annoncé qu'il irait en chine désormais
tous les ans on les écoute il a affiché
dès son arrivée et son ambition
notamment pour la planète
jeu
dans une année franco chinois de la
transition et bleu
2018 2019 pour mobiliser nos entreprises
nos startups chercheurs de cette union
les universités de villes des régions
pour démontrer aux que nous français et
chinois sommes capables de faire de
notre planète soit à nouveau grand des
pelles de donner corps à cette phrase
gens disent you the
wall alors qu'est ce que je pensais
surtout chinois n'ont comme dirait que
je dérange beaucoup je n'entends pas le
chinois d'accord mais peut-être alors un
peu plus loin parce que s qu'il prend la
place par exemple laissée vacante par
les américains par donald trump
totalement en chine écoutez je ne sais
pas s'il prend le on prend pas la place
d'un altran ben franchement telle
générosité
réunis dans le pacifique et
sont absolument immense c'est sont
assurés dans des conditions aussi
erratique et confuse qu'aujourd'hui
c'est extrêmement grave et personne en
europe ne peut actuellement supplée aux
etats unis en revanche que dit emmanuel
macron et qui me paraît de plus un bon
sens c'est que notre avenir passe
inévitablement qu'on aime ou qu'on
n'aime pas par l'intensification des
relations avec ce qui est objectivement
la première puissance et quand même
venir monsieur penser qu'on l'a entendu
il ya quelques jours avec le président
turc ont longtemps aujourd'hui en chine
on entend plein gala merkel par exemple
c'est normal écoutez on est dans une
situation où et c'est une
caractéristique delà de la situation
européenne aujourd'hui où monsieur
emmanuel mâcon a été élu dans des
conditions assez brillante il a
complètement bouleversé le système
politique il a constitué une majorité
d'un type entièrement nouveau de centre
droit et le centre gauche qui est une
majorité par nature par excellence
européenne et et il a donc il a donc
réussi quelque chose une sorte d
d'extraordinaire il est confronté à des
partenaires qui sont tous en difficulté
trump à l'extérieur des états inférieure
et trempette ans est victime madame mais
est dans une situation impossible
madame merkel et quoi il faut lui
laisser le temps elle a besoin de
costard deux prochaines semaines voire
de plusieurs mois et pour résoudre les
graves parce que c'est grave ce
sont les choses lentement et
que ces journées sans ce moteur
franco-allemand dont on nous rebat les
oreilles de mes yeux le moteur fantôme
franco-allemand marchera mais je crois
je crois à ce qu'en latin on appelait le
festival nt le à toi lentement de la
tortue les allemands ont toujours
fonctionné comme ça ils payent mettent
ils font les choses progressivement ils
les font sérieusement et je suis
convaincu qu'on arrivera à avoir une
majorité déterminés dans quelques mois
je ne suis pas sûr en revanche qu'il n'y
ait pas un malentendu entre les français
et les allemands sur le degré de
transformation qu'on doit réaliser en
europe je pense que la grande différence
entre les allemands et les français
c'est que les allemands sont satisfaits
de l'europe telle qu'elle est à
condition que tout le monde fasse
respecte les traités et fassent ce
qu'ils doivent faire alors qu'en france
un peuple éternellement mécontents sa
division 2 ceux qui n'en veulent pas et
ceux qui en veulent plus et donc on
n'est pas tout à fait au diapason ça
c'est le rôle d'un homme d'état que
d'arrivées organisé ça c'est qu'ils ont
un problème de rajoy on a le problème de
2,2 des italiens de donc tous tous nos
partenaires sont en situation va là la
plupart de nos partenaires sont en
situation très difficile je crois qu'il
faut pas que ça dure je pense qu'on ne
fera pas l'europe sur l'affaiblissement
durable de tout le monde vous parler de
la france et de ceux qui ne veulent pas
vous fait peut-être une petite
parenthèse
comment vous considèrent aujourd'hui la
façon dont laurent wauquiez patron des
républicains voient cette europe cette
façon un peu eurosceptiques puisqu'elle
vous inquiet je crois que ce qui
caractérise laurent wauquiez en matière
européenne comme dans beaucoup de
domaines c'est l'opportunisme c'est à
dire que c'est quelqu'un qui a choisi de
s'opposer à au centre droit au centre
gauche à la gauche sur deux thèmes la
question européenne et la question
identitaire et la question des des
immigrés fait ça pour des raisons
strictement électoral alors je crois que
sur les questions européennes ça ne le
conduira nulle part parce que la messe
est dite je veux dire que la messe a été
dite au moment de l'élection
présidentielle les français ont
clairement dit après d'autres après les
grecs notamment à mon avis le grand
virage ça a été de sipera ce type race
qui critiquent l'euro qui dit c'est pas
bon pour la grèce et qui quand il a
commis l'erreur sortiront une erreur
politique ça serait non non je crois que
c'est très significatif savez j'ai une
idée un peu paradoxal sur lol là la
crise et la relance de l'europe je crois
que la relance de l'europe et filles de
la crise de l'europe je crois que quand
la crise de l'europe est entrée dans une
période dramatique c'est à dire avec la
crise de l'euro à ce moment là les
opinions publiques se sont ressaisis
avant c'était une idée on était content
l'europe ça faisait bien ou pour
l'europe mais ça n'avait pas beaucoup de
conséquences tandis que l'un ou s'est
dit est ce qu'on sort ou pas de l'euro
est bien la cale réponse globale des
européens c'est non nous devons garder
l'euro et nous devons fédérer nos
efforts sur le terrorisme sur la
sécurité car nous avons partie liés les
uns avec les autres vu de france la
réponse à l'europe parce que c'est une
grande coalition avec notamment la jupe
et pour une liste aux élèves les photos
macro par exemple je ne sais pas comment
ça va évoluer en politique intérieure je
crois que le grand problème qui est
posée c'est de savoir comment la
majorité actuelle va se situer dans le
concert du parlement européen parce que
le parlement européen on
on n'attend pas que les français les
français vont jouer un rôle important
mais est ce que les français veulent
rentrer au ppe ce qui poserait quand
même les français c'est à dire dans
marche ce qui poserait un grave problème
parce que c'est quand même un parti où
il ya les hongrois de monsieur or ban
par exemple alors que monsieur macron
dit à juste titre bonbons ou toutes les
réserves qu'il a sur les atteintes à la
démocratie dans ce pays bon est-ce que
ils vont se joindre aux socialistes ça
paraît aussi assez paradoxal est-ce
qu'ils vont rejoindre le groupe des
libéraux et des démocrates dans lequel
dont fait partie le modem et parti
démocrate européen ce serait a priori la
solution la plus rationnelle c'est pas
lieu à ce qu'ils veulent faire un groupe
à partir des manuels bacon à une sorte
d' en marche européen hélas là il faut
que ça il faut que les gens suivent un
et là je crois que ça dépendra de
beaucoup de choses effectivement si
monsieur renzi l'emportent en italie et
ça n'a rien d'évident qui l'emportent en
italie ça serait une possibilité mais il
faut voir un aveugle je crois qu'il
faudrait plutôt qu'ils se rapprochent du
modem sur ce plan c'est en tout cas
montré le chemin les l'udf d'abord et le
modem ensuite c'est nous qui avons
montré le chemin en étant dans un groupe
qui est exactement au centre de
l'échiquier politique à strasbourg
est-ce que emmanuel macron a eu raison
de fermer la porte de l'europe à la
turquie comme on l'a entendu l'autre
jour il l'a dit devant le président
horaires de à paris moi je suis tout à
fait d'accord avec les approches c'est à
dire la proche qui consiste à dire on a
plein de choses à faire avec la turquie
bien qu'elles ne respectent absolument
pas nos valeurs les principes auxquels
nous tenons mais ça je suis de l'avis de
védrines on ne fait pas de la politique
avec des gens avec lesquels dont on
partage simplement les valeurs est-ce
que d'ici nous ont fait un petit club
mais en revanche la grande erreur à
laquelle d'ailleurs à participer védrine
puisqu'il était 19h en gérant voir - du
conseil européen d'helsinki la grande
erreur ça a été de dire qu'il pouvait
être intégré l'union européenne il faut
distinguer deux choses coopérait avec la
turquie oui tout a intégré ont intégré
dans l'union européenne n'ont toutes
leurs questions très court la pologne on
a décroché l'article 7 qui permet un peu
de
de contraindre la pologne sur certaines
choses c'est une erreur ou pas on verra
c'est c'est très difficile il faut y
aller en pologne encore d'énormes
réserves de défense de la cause
européenne de solidarnosc que des droits
de la personne je n'ai je trouve que je
trouve que l'église l'église notamment
le vatican ne se mobilise pas assez pour
rappeler aux européens ont rappelé aux
polonais par non les valeurs
fondamentales dont ils devraient se
reconnaître je pense qu'il ne faut pas
agresser psychologiquement la pologne et
en même temps il faut reconnaître qu'au
gouvernement polonais se fiche un peu du
monde dans un message au pape on termine
par un message au pape polonais le qui
devrait être un peu voilà merci beaucoup
merci jean louis bourlanges merci à tous
à la semaine prochaine lundi
[Musique]